you've done all of this stuff right
you've done the sale selection week
three times strapping the legs up so
that you can run a bad water Ultra race
the Asperger's everything yes of all of
the physical Pursuits that you've
endured which has been the most painful
by far by far
my first hundred mile race
by far this 2019 Moab the one that ID
enough but still finished that's up
there
but when you are
um so I guess you're you're not prepared
to run 100 miles
and you take it for granted
and you didn't do any training at all
and you had the right nutrition
and off a whim
like literally like you know what I want
to raise money for a foundation that's
how that happened so I don't know if you
know a story or not but basically I'm
sitting there and the Lone Survivor
incident happened with a bunch of you
know some seals died I want to raise
money for him I went to training with
most of these guys
so I had the bright idea to uh raise
money you know I wasn't gonna do a hot
dog or hamburger sale I was gonna do
something that people would be attracted
to so I Googled the world's toughest
events
and where it comes up is this race
called the badwater 135. it's 135 mile
race through Death Valley in the
summertime
now I had no idea about ultra running I
know what the [__] ultra running was but
when I heard so when I saw 135 miles
I automatically assumed it was a stage
race where you ran like maybe 10 15
miles bed down and you got next morning
did it so when I call the race director
up Chris Kaufman I'm like hey I would
like to do this race to raise money for
a foundation he goes have you ever run
100 miles
and I was like like in in a week or like
like were you talking about he goes no
like in 24 hours because that's what you
got to do to qualify and I was like is
that even is that even possible like I I
no so anyway
he goes no you can't get in my race
unless you qualify
and I call him up on a Wednesday
and that Saturday and I was a
bodybuilder at the time I did cardio 20
minutes a week on the elliptical trainer
every Sunday
he goes yeah Saturday you're in San
Diego Saturday is a 24-hour race where
you run around a one mile track for 24
hours and if you can get 100 miles
I'll consider you in my race
so I'll go sign up for this race
and the first 70 miles I'm doing pretty
good
and then I hadn't sat down I was uh had
to go in the bathroom I was eating I was
drinking mild Plex and Rich crackers I
was you know eating Rich crackers Elite
nutrition yeah elite elite high quality
nutrition
so what happens when you're that
ignorant
and you go out to do this race and you
sit down in the chair your body's done
so I'm sitting there and when you sit
down for the first time in over 12 hours
your body's now going through some
metamorphosis
like go [__] at home go go to a doctor
get some help
but I'm sitting there and I have this
urge to go to the bathroom
and there's a porta potty for me that
[__] wall but I can't get up because
my blood pressure's all messed up from
my great nutrition that was on and so I
can't stand up
so I look at my ex-wife and I literally
say I want to [__] on myself right now
so I sit there and I'm [__] up my
back and I'm peeing blood down my leg
and I have 30 miles to go
and I end up finding a way
to get through that 30 miles and when I
got done with that race
it's the worst pain
I can ever even I can't even describe
the pain of that last 30 miles to
anybody no one it's very hard whole body
whole body
um so when it ended I I I'm literally
dizzy going up my stairs to get to my
house I'm literally I have my arms
wrapped around her going up the stairs
and every flight of stairs I gotta have
to lay down because I can't stay upright
for too long or I'm gonna pass out so I
finally get in the house and I get in
the house I'm once again on the floor
I'm in the kitchen on the floor just
laying there I finally make it to the
bathroom
into the tub I get rolled in the tub and
she puts the water on me I'm just laying
there with the water coming on me
and what I pee out looks like Coca-Cola
and I'm laying there in the worst pain
of my entire life
I'm shaking I'm jacked up
and all I could think about was
I can't believe what I just done
because when you get to 70 miles of a
race and you felt the way I did
it's to me it was humanly impossible
to even think about going 30 more miles
in that shape and once you do it what
what came over me when that shower hit
me and the reality hit that
I spent 101 miles
in that last 31 miles was something that
I can't even describe to people
and she's like we gotta get to the
hospital
so at the time my mom was seeing this
doctor and he was like you know so so
she's describing to my mom I'm going
through he's like you gotta get in the
hospital now
and I just said just just shut up
and let me enjoy this pain
I don't want anything to numb it I don't
want anything right now because what I
had done was I just in my mind
and people will take this wrong and take
as long as you want to I don't really
care I had just climbed a mental wall
that was amazing and I didn't want
anybody to take that pain away from me
at that point because I was that was all
confirmation it seems like I've heard
you tell that story a number of times
it's amazing
did that set the tone or the Rhythm for
what you wanted to try and Achieve and
feel again each time this you're pushing
further there's more difficulty I never
want to feel it again
I never want to feel it again but what
it did was it showed me what is possible
and that's what set the new stage for me
that's when I realized oh man I've
really been underachieving my entire
life I'm not saying that you have to go
to that place because that place is a
dangerous dangerous place that
borderline rhabdo hot everything
it was all that yeah but you know
you don't want to go there but it taught
me what is possible so from that 19-hour
lesson one of the best biggest lesson in
my life it taught me like okay
I got it check
this episode is brought to you by
element element is a tasty electrolyte
drink mix with everything that you need
and nothing that you don't I've replaced
my morning coffee with element every day
for over three years now and I've never
looked back it means I've optimized my
hydration my brain feels better I'm not
getting mental fog and it's helping me
to curb Cravings if I'm fasting
throughout the day even video guy Dean
uses it my favorite flavor is the orange
that in a cold glass of water upon
waking feels really really good it's a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium which
helps me to feel my absolute best all
day also they have a no BS no questions
asked refund policy so you can buy it
and try it for an unlimited amount of
time and if you do not like it they'll
give you your money back and you don't
even need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it head
to drink
lmnt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink
lmnt.com
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Goggins then press here for the full
episode in all of its glory and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]